maintenant j'en arrive à passer quelque
chose de très sérieux
vas-y ouais je suis prêt c'est l'anti
portrait chinois
ah j'adore ça voilà jean marie bigard
elle fait bouger
ouais si vous étiez un défaut la
gentillesse ouais mais c'est un super
défaut ça on n'est pas à l'abri
d'ailleurs de la gentillesse des autres
si vous êtes une injure allez tous vous
faire [ __ ]
ça a le mérite d'être clair oui si vous
étiez une maladie une maladie je serai
peut-être la maladie ah oui je serai la
maladie de
gilles de la tourette tu connais ce
mardi j'ai vu ça l'autre jour c'est
extraordinaire si ea mais qui parle
normalement
ouais c'est comme un tick tock chu dans
sa paix et tout d'un coup le mec sort
une insanité quoi ouais tu parles avec
lui tu dis grattieri j'aime bien ton
émission va te faire [ __ ] cas là mais
il ya on voit pas assez souvent
laurent baffie twilight continue à
parler normalement mais aussi el haimer
c'est pas mal
ouais d'ailleurs tu sais que robinson
crusoé sur la fin de sa vie il avait la
maladie d'alzheimer ah bon tu sais
comment ils appelaient vendredi
non l'autre jour
jean marie bigard si vous étiez un
accident je suis un accident mais oui si
vous étiez une perversion je suis une
perversion je m'équipe il passa vas-y
enchaîne juste y ait une guerre
je serai la guerre des boutons ce que la
guerre maintenant c'est avec des boutons
paris et puis elle se fait
économiquement il des boutons tu vois
bien un jk les propres soit disant tu te
rends compte quand un mec sur un bouton
un bon père de famille dit bon l'embargo
au godinand l'embargo ouais il appuie
sur un bouton y tu as cru sur 3500
personnes par jour par exemple l'embargo
sur l'irak qui a tué un million et demi
de personnes dont cinq cent mille
enfants de moins de cinq ans simplement
toi ici et bien aligné toit cinq cent
mille enfants toi là j'ai pas vu
beaucoup de minutes de silence pour ça
non mais un embargo ça tue à coups sûrs
et et puis bon bah voilà donc c'est la
lèque ça serait vraiment la guerre des
boutons si vous étiez une arme je serai
excalibur si j'étais une house déjà
parce qu'elle sait pas tirer par tout le
monde comme d'hab il remarquer et qui
s'émiette on servir tu peux pourfendre
un certain nombre de groupes avec dexia
lur saluces calibur de monsieur
voilà bien sûr
si vous étiez une cicatrice cicatrices
la cicatrice de l'appendicite parce que
c'est pas loin de la salle des fêtes
si vous étiez un poison
je serai une femme ouais
allez go
tj doute un samassa temps quand on en
bouffe avec des amis je ne tourne vers
ma femme et je dis tu es toi toi mal
baisées et grâce à qui ça veut dire à
toi chérie
bon alors puis ceux qui commandent
ah justement si vous étiez une [ __ ]
ce sera une chouette genre béatrice
dalle tu vois ouais parce que j'adore
béatrice à la question contraire même
s'il adore super g maintenant en plus
quelque chose on est là parce que c'est
non je dis j'ai dit béatrice dalle parce
que c'est le type de fille qui est
d'ailleurs de cordialement détesté par
les autres femmes a certainement parce
que c'est vrai que tu as envie de
grimper dessus et tu sais que tu vas
jamais y arriver quoi et dont je suis
très fantasmé league
si vous étiez un dictateur
charlie chaplin si etienne assassin
rocco siffredi
je le fais
est ce que c'est une idée de film je
sais que je serai un serial buteur mais
qui tuerait des blondes à coups de beats
alors rechercherait note de la france
ça va ça si vous étiez une torture une
torture un truc pire que jean pierre
foucault un jeu c'est pas le jeu serait
un vélo un vélo c'est une torture la
preuve les ils sont obligés de prendre
de la drogue pour mon métier c'est à
dire que c'est dur c'est quand même à
vélo la sueur des gonaïves et le
truqueur ah oui
oui c'est le mélo cas michel vaucaire à
néant
michaëlle jean lé ballon rouler
c'est génial ça c'est devant le michaël
blanc mais le bien sur lequel tu vois
rien demandé à moi bah tu peux donner ce
que tu veux un jeune claudia n'ont
peut-être pas mais non mais qu'est ce
que je vais te donner a fléchi et
maintenant
à
non
voilà le lot soit sous la table des
caméras castrais les caméras et de le
saison mickaël alors pour le micro je
fais comment battu non mais le slip sais
pas c'est pas suffisant tiens tu sais tu
sais tu sais que depuis bercy
je ne quitte pas si chaussures oui parce
que c'est elle qui sont entrés devant
les 13000 bâtonnets et ben je donne les
chaussures et le seul et le liban
merci c'est bon michel blanc au village
côté l'as bien mérité
en question
au musée
oui
placé devant lui
voilà amical si puissant pote cabane
avec juin
je trouve ça vachement bien que gasquet
devrait d'abord réussi le sortir de là
parce que le mec il y à perpète ses
impressions de cristal il a pris 22 ans
avoir tué six gonzesses et lui pour un
peu de shit il est à perpète donc si on
arrive à faire bouger ça et si tu y
arrives et ben c'est vachement bien mais
ça va faire école bah ouais il faudrait
que chirac l'avait un peu aussi un brave
asie jacques et alain jacques un civil
est il mort
je serai une petite mort c'est la petite
mort ouais la petite bord que tu as vu
dans les yeux de ta femme comme il l'a
fait jouir à coup en 69 jours marie
bizarre
rémi de vos vues sur la ville